- I had a couple of
friends visit last week
and I borrowed a golf cart
and I was showing them the town square,
and the tram came by, the
one with all the tourists
and I was like, oh what
am I supposed to do?
Am I recognizable or am I not?
So the tram pulls up,
I'm in this little golf
cart with my friends,
and people are looking at the clock tower
which is the other way
and I was like, let me
discreetly get outta here,
so I went to go hit the gas,
but the horn is next to the gas,
and I hit the horn and all of
the people turned this way,
and I was like, well now I don't know
what I'm supposed to do,
So I was like, sorry everybody!
And they all just went.
And so I was like
okay, well I guessed I waved
and I was part of the tour.
- I love that!
Bet you made their day!
- I hope it was fun.
- You get recognized all the time?
- It depends.
You know, I've done the kinds of movies
where usually people have
had a few before they,
whatever I'm allowed to do.
- Partake.
- Partaken before they watch
in their living room.
- It's daytime,
it's legal here, it's fine.
- Oh yeah, true.
So look, some of them are party movies.
So sometimes I'll be at a bar
and people will recognize me
or think they recognize me,
but actually recognize
Aziz, or Kunal Nayyar,
- [Kelly] No!
- I know!
This is not supposed to be a dark story.
(audience laughing)
I became guilty of, if
I'm out with friends
and I'm not having the best day,
and if somebody is a
little drunk and goes,
Are you Kal Penn?
I've been known to go, what do
you think we all look alike?
No!
(Kelly laughs)
And I feel bad.
- But it's funny!
- I feel bad, I mean usually I'll be like,
I'm totally kidding, I'm totally kidding!
But I have gotten a couple of free beers
of of Aziz and Kunal.
So I gotta, you know.